Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Ouch
Jake:我我我这么拉吧
Jake: I'll do it like this
Jake:不用洗手我会啦
Jake: No need to wash your hands, I got it
Jake:我会了你不用洗手
Jake: I've got it, no need to wash your hands
Jake:你咋还没开灯呢
Jake: Why haven't you turned on the light?
Tasha:咦
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha:你把它拉这么长试试
Tasha: Try pulling it this long
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha:行然后我们再多拉几次
Tasha: Alright, let's pull it a few more times
Tasha:拉这么长就行
Tasha: Just like this
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK
Tasha:差不多可以了
Tasha: That should be enough
Tasha:我第一次把它放这么久拉
Tasha: It's my first time leaving it this long
Jake:会有差别吗
Jake: Will it make a difference?
Tasha:不知道耶
Tasha: No idea
Jake:会有差别吗
Jake: Will it make a difference?
Jake:哎哟 我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Tasha:好了好了
Tasha: Alright, alright
Tasha:算了来吧
Tasha: Never mind, let's go
Jake:为什么还要再打几次
Jake: Why do we need to do it a few more times?
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: No idea
Katrina: 把他拉上吧
Katrina: Pull it up
Jake:这个麻糬对吧
Jake: This mochi, right?
Tasha:对你拉
Tasha: Yeah, you pull it
Tasha:然后你把它们放在这个球这个碗里
Tasha: Then put them in this bowl
Tasha:必须要由你来放干净因为
Tasha: You have to put it in clean because
Tasha:嗯第二个摸面团的人
Tasha: Hmm, the second person to touch the dough
Tasha:手就会被粘住
Tasha: will get their hands sticky.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:手
Tasha: Hands.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why is that?
Tasha:面团很 柔  你你手上有油了
Tasha: The dough is very soft, and your hands are oily.
Tasha:那个黄油在你手上
Tasha: The butter is on your hands.
Tasha:你想让你再揉一会吧我帮你搞个配件
Tasha: Do you want to knead it a bit more? I'll get you a fitting.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 这要唱素颜吗
Katrina: Are we singing "Su Yan"?
Katrina: 但确实是一首国民歌曲
Katrina: But it really is a national hit.
Shure: 变成情歌对唱了是吧
Shure: It's turned into a love duet, right?
Jake:对感情你
Jake: Yeah, about love.
Jake:两个人唱是吧
Jake: Two people singing, right?
Katrina: 这是分男女生
Katrina: It's split into male and female parts.
Katrina: 就是许嵩跟一个人
Katrina: It's Xu Song and someone.
Jake:哦哦哦我知道
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, I know.
Shure: 我一对4唱好吧哈哈哈
Shure: I'll sing against four people, how about that? Hahaha.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 揉就这面试要做什么
Katrina: What are we making with this dough?
Jake:呃现在做做麻薯
Jake: Uh, now we're making mochi.
Katrina: 哇每天晚上都有加餐哎
Katrina: Wow, we have extra snacks every night.
Jake:确实比较
Jake: It's quite...
Katrina: 麻薯好像可以放好几天哎
Katrina: Mochi can be stored for several days.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Katrina: 哦原来麻薯是这样做的嗯
Katrina: Oh, so that's how mochi is made.
Katrina: 感觉你在这几天也修炼了不少技能
Katrina: It feels like you've honed a lot of skills these past few days.
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Indeed, indeed.
Shure: 你回去直接可以新加坡
Shure: You can go straight to Singapore.
Shure: 新加坡
Shure: Singapore.
Jake:对对对新加坡开店对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, open a shop in Singapore.
Katrina: 新加坡开一个cake cake店
Katrina: Open a cake shop in Singapore.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 就叫EGO
Shure: Call it EGO.
Katrina: EGO cake
Katrina: EGO cake.
Jake:哈哈哈EGO cake可以可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, EGO cake, sure, sure, sure.
Jake:EGO Bakery可以可以
Jake: EGO Bakery, sure, sure.
Jake:然后所有加热材料都是显卡
Jake: And all the heating materials will be graphics cards.
Jake:就主打显卡
Jake: Just focus on graphics cards.
Katrina: 一个蛋糕换一张显卡
Katrina: One cake for one graphics card.
Katrina: 一个一个显卡换一张蛋糕
Katrina: One graphics card for one cake.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这个可以这个可以
Jake: This is good, this is good.
Jake:这个我喜欢我靠
Jake: I like this, oh my god.
Katrina: 定一下
Katrina: Decide.
Jake:哎呀我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 你最拿手的吧
Katrina: This is your specialty, right?
Tasha:这个是
Tasha: This is...
Tasha:好求你
Tasha: Alright, please.
Tasha:好然后下一锅子
Tasha: Okay, then the next pot.
Tasha:我等一下就告诉你
Tasha: I'll tell you in a bit.
Tasha:嗯 你把它挤出一个球来你懂吗
Tasha: Mm, squeeze it into a ball, you get it?
Jake:我试试
Jake: I'll give it a try.
Tasha:对就这样子
Tasha: Yes, just like that.
Shure: 那个杨老板
Shure: Hey, Jake.
Tasha:哎干嘛
Tasha: Hey, what's up?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 把那个手机号给尼蔻斯发一下呗
Shure: Send that phone number to Nicous.
Shure: 路亚的
Shure: The one from Luya.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 把路亚的手机号给那个那谁发一下
Shure: Send Luya's number to, you know who.
Jake:手机号啊
Jake: The phone number?
Shure: 他联系不到路亚现在
Shure: He can't reach Luya right now.
Jake:OK行
Jake: OK, sure.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哎哎哎帮我把手机拿出来
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, get my phone out.
Jake:我靠你看
Jake: Oh my god, look.
Tasha:哇你真厉害哎
Tasha: Wow, you're amazing.
Jake:好玩
Jake: This is fun.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Good.
Jake:爱玩
Jake: I love it.
Tasha:你已经爱上厨房了
Tasha: You've fallen in love with the kitchen.
Jake:对确实
Jake: Yeah, for sure.
Tasha:手机在哪里哦
Tasha: Where's the phone?
Jake:在我在我兜里
Jake: It's in my pocket.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:打开刷我的脸
Jake: Unlock it with my face.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Tasha:然后
Tasha: Then...
Jake:打打电话
Jake: Make a call.
Jake:哎那谢彬竹去哪了
Jake: Hey, where did Xie Binzhu go?
Tasha:谢谢明竹去哪了
Tasha: Where did Xie Míngzhu go?
Jake:谢谢彬竹
Jake: Xie Binzhu.
Jake:就刚刚那小伙
Jake: That guy from before.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:他跟他出去了吗
Tasha: Did he go out with him?
Jake:路亚他玩狗的时候
Jake: When Luya was playing with the dog.
Jake:这个不是被狗抓了一下吗
Jake: Didn't the dog scratch him?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:然后他觉得不放心
Jake: Then he felt uneasy.
Jake:他去打疫苗去了
Jake: So he went to get vaccinated.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:然后他我们我们也不放心
Jake: And we, we also felt uneasy.
Jake:所以派小伙去接他了
Jake: So we sent a guy to pick him up.
Jake:然后那小伙接就
Jake: But that guy couldn't...
Jake:就是联系不上露亚
Jake: He couldn't reach Luya.
Jake:然后再想办法
Jake: So now we're figuring it out.
小薇 我刷到什么
Tasha: What did I just see?
Jake:关了吧 打电话给谢彬竹退出去
Jake: Just turn it off. Call Xie Binzhu and tell him to come back.
Tasha:这个是吗
Tasha: Is it this one?
Jake:对打
Jake: Yeah, call him.
Shure: 我给谢彬竹拿把伞下雨了
Shure: I'll get an umbrella for Xie Binzhu, it's raining.
Tasha:这个不是视频
Tasha: This isn't a video.
Shure: 来抱着他吧
Shure: Come on, hold him.
Nicous: 喂
Nicous: Hello?
Jake:你在哪
Jake: Where are you?
Shure: 你装个逼 好的
Shure: You're just showing off, huh?
Nicous: 大门口
Nicous: At the main entrance.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:啊卧槽
Jake: Oh damn.
Jake:那你他妈进来不就行了吗
Jake: Why don't you just come in?
Jake:打什么电话呀
Jake: Why are you calling?
Nicous: 不是 刚刚
Nicous: No, just now...
Shure: 你给他拿把伞啊
Shure: Get him an umbrella.
Tasha:拿把伞
Tasha: Get an umbrella.
Jake:拿把伞干嘛
Jake: Why an umbrella?
Shure: 他他要把伞
Shure: He, he wants an umbrella.
Nicous: 刚刚在
Nicous: Just now at...
Jake:下雨了
Jake: It's raining.
Nicous: 刚刚在咖啡厅
Nicous: Just now at the café.
Nicous: 就下雨了
Nicous: It started raining.
Nicous: 回来拿把伞
Nicous: Came back to get an umbrella.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Nicous: 她有手机号吗
Nicous: Does she have a phone number?
Jake:他有手机号
Jake: He has a phone number.
Jake:你怎么跑咖啡厅去了
Jake: Why did you go to the coffee shop?
Nicous: 她 没理我
Nicous: She ignored me.
Jake:没理你你他妈找我还去咖啡厅干嘛
Jake: She ignored you, and you still came to the coffee shop? What the hell?
Jake:你干嘛啊
Jake: What are you doing?
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Huh?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Nicous: 怎么
Nicous: What?
Jake:没他没理你
Jake: She ignored you.
Jake:你过来找我
Jake: And you came to find me.
Nicous: 我过来准备打电话的
Nicous: I came over to make a call.
Jake:啊结果呢
Jake: And then?
Nicous: 下雨了没带伞
Nicous: It started raining and I didn’t have an umbrella.
Jake:哦行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:这样吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Jake:我靠这么牛逼
Jake: Wow, that’s impressive.
Jake:这样
Jake: So...
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:来 拿着你给谢彬竹拿着
Jake: Here, take this to Xie Binzhu.
Jake:然后退回去
Jake: Then head back.
Jake:露亚
Jake: Lucia.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:你点你点你点你点
Jake: You, you, you, you.
Jake:然后点头像
Jake: Then click the avatar.
Jake:对哎我操
Jake: Yes, oh crap.
Jake:他不应该有的
Jake: He shouldn’t have it.
Nicous: 她不是有简历吗
Nicous: Doesn’t she have a resume?
Jake:有简历
Jake: She has a resume.
Tasha:文件找文件找文件
Tasha: Find the file, find the file, find the file.
Jake:找文件
Jake: Find the file.
Jake:有吗
Jake: Is it there?
Nicous: 有
Nicous: Yes.
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:行行行来
Jake: Alright, alright, come on.
Jake:那个你你先打个电话吧
Jake: Hey, you go ahead and make a call first.
Jake:先打个电话
Jake: Make the call first.
Jake:喂露亚我是谢宾珠我来接你了就是这样
Jake: Hello, Luya, this is Xie Binzhu. I'm here to pick you up, that's it.
Tasha:搓球吧
Tasha: Let's play ball.
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright, sure.
Jake:我把
Jake: I'll...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:哦行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:给你个任务
Jake: I have a task for you.
Jake:去接路亚吧
Jake: Go pick up Luya.
Jake: :她眼镜是在下面吗
Jake: Are her glasses downstairs?
Jake: :对 拿着
Jake: Yeah, take them.
Jake:唉谢彬竹接到了吗
Jake: Hey, Xie Binzhu, did you get her?
Jake:我我给你
Jake: I'll...
Jake:你去拿充电宝
Jake: You go get the power bank.
Alice:拿几个啊
Alice: How many should I take?
Jake:在这边
Jake: Over here.
Jake:拿一个
Jake: Just take one.
Jake:拿一个就够你拿个高的
Jake: One is enough, get the tall one.
Jake:40吧 他没这么高呢那个不是更高吗
Jake: About 40. It's not that tall, isn't there a taller one?
Jake:那个后面的
Jake: The one at the back.
Jake:我靠不行那就拿40走
Jake: Oh, never mind, just take the 40.
Alice:我去哪里接她
Alice: Where should I pick her up?
Jake:啊你跟谢彬竹走
Jake: Ah, go with Xie Binzhu.
Jake:那个他的定位给发给我了
Jake: He sent me her location.
Jake:顺着那个定位过去就行
Jake: Just follow the location.
Nicous: 好
Nicous: Okay.
Jake:露亚还行吧
Jake: Is Luya alright?
Nicous: 她说她打好了
Nicous: She said she's ready.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Nicous: 她已经打好了
Nicous: She's already ready.
Jake:好吧接她一下
Jake: Okay, go pick her up.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:是开车去吗
Tasha: Are we driving there?
Jake:打车打车打车去对
Jake: Take a cab, take a cab, yeah.
Alice:这么远吗
Alice: Is it that far?
Jake:没有很远就是安全一点
Jake: Not really, just to be safe.
Alice:那我不换鞋了
Alice: Then I won't change my shoes.
Jake:你不用换鞋了
Jake: You don't need to.
Jake:来 我要干嘛
Jake: Alright, what should I do now?
Tasha:您挤吧 挤
Tasha: Go ahead, squeeze it.
Tasha:就是这样挤一个出来
Tasha: Just squeeze one out like this.
Tasha:大了
Tasha: It's too big.
Tasha:啊对 然后捏出来
Tasha: Ah yes, then pinch it out.
Tasha:捏啊用另一只手
Tasha: Pinch it with the other hand.
Tasha:先捏个团子 然后 嗯
Tasha: First, make a ball, then... mmhmm.
Tasha:唵
Tasha: Mmhmm.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:好大哦
Tasha: It's so big.
Alice:村头
Alice: At the village entrance.
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Tasha:好粘啊你别搞这么粘乎呀
Tasha: So sticky, don't make it so sticky.
Katrina: 感觉好跑调啊我
Katrina: I feel so off-key.
Tasha:就直接挤进去就行
Tasha: Just squeeze it in directly.
Tasha:你放进去
Tasha: Put it in.
Jake:它为什么这么粘
Jake: Why is it so sticky?
Tasha:就是所以我的手更不能沾
Tasha: That's why my hands shouldn't touch it.
Tasha:你都已经这么粘了
Tasha: Your hands are already so sticky.
Jake:哇靠
Jake: Wow.
Jake:这这这地方我我一只手搞能搞定吗
Jake: Can I handle this with one hand?
Tasha:搞不定
Tasha: No, you can't.
Jake:谢谢 我能搞定
Jake: Thanks, I can handle it.
Tasha:别用别用那一只手啊 哈
Tasha: Don't use that hand, haha.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:这样这样是不是挺好
Jake: Is this good like this?
Tasha:我 两只手可以搞定的
Tasha: I can handle it with both hands.
Jake:这样这样行吗
Jake: Is this okay?
Tasha:可以了 你扔进去就行了
Tasha: Yes, just throw it in.
Shure: 哎你还有没有什么其他想法
Shure: Hey, do you have any other ideas?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:这 这也挤点
Tasha: Squeeze this, too.
Tasha:大概挤3-5个就可以
Tasha: Squeeze about 3-5 of them.
Tasha:换
Tasha: Change it.
Tasha:可以换
Tasha: You can change it.
Tasha:全部挤出来就行了
Tasha: Just squeeze them all out.
Jake:这个太大了
Jake: This is too big.
Tasha:好好好没事没事你想多大多大
Tasha: It's fine, make it as big as you want.
Jake:哈哈哈这个我喜欢
Jake: Haha, I like this.
Jake:这么说话我就喜欢
Jake: I like it when you talk like this.
Shure: perfect是吧咱又开始唱perfect
Shure: Perfect, right? Let's start singing "Perfect" again.
Tasha:揪出来就这样直接扔进去好吧
Tasha: Just pull it out and throw it in, okay?
Tasha:好吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, hahaha.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:为什么可以怎么可以
Jake: Why? How can this be?
Tasha:它太喜欢你啦
Tasha: It really likes you!
Jake:暂时不用我靠
Jake: Not now, oh my gosh.
Jake:我靠哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Jake:吃的时候你才喜欢我
Jake: You only like me when you eat.
Shure: 我们就抛砖引玉
Shure: We are just setting the stage.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:手
Tasha: Your hand.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:下不去啊
Jake: It's not going down.
Tasha:手套要是破了话这个时候就很好弄了
Tasha: If the glove breaks, it would be easier to handle now.
Jake:那这不破了吗
Jake: Isn't it broken now?
Tasha:为什么破
Tasha: Why is it broken?
Tasha:你不
Tasha: You don't...
Jake:是不是太大了
Jake: Is it too big?
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:没事继续挤吧
Tasha: It's okay, keep squeezing.
Tasha:给他翻个面你也可以继续挤
Tasha: Turn it over, you can keep squeezing.
Tasha:太粘了抓紧点
Tasha: It's too sticky, hold tighter.
Shure: 他夹不紧
Shure: He can't grip it tight.
Tasha:你也给拉紧
Tasha: You also pull it tight.
Jake:我为什么只有5只手指
Jake: Why do I only have 5 fingers?
Tasha:你还想要几只
Tasha: How many do you want?
Tasha:我来满足你的愿望
Tasha: I can fulfill your wish.
Jake:你怎么满足我的愿望
Jake: How will you fulfill my wish?
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:来哈哈哈
Jake: Come on, hahaha.
Jake:不好 就这样子
Jake: Not good, just like this.
Tasha:哎 您尽量往粉上倒呀
Tasha: Hey, try to pour it onto the powder.
Tasha:您往壁个倒不太好扒拉下来
Tasha: If you pour it on the side, it's hard to scrape down.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:您看
Tasha: Look.
Jake:好 可以
Jake: Okay, got it.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:好我错了
Jake: Okay, my bad.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha:好好好我来吧你的手
Tasha: Okay, okay, let me do it, your hand.
Tasha:这样子的话面团上面就都是巧克力
Tasha: If we do it this way, the dough will be covered in chocolate.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:所以这个步骤需要两个人
Tasha: So this step needs two people.
Jake:我明白
Jake: I understand.
Tasha:其实你那个步骤很好玩的
Tasha: Actually, your step is quite fun.
Tasha:只不过你的手套不好
Tasha: It's just that your gloves are not good.
Jake:为什么只有一个手套呢一双手套呢
Jake: Why is there only one glove? Shouldn't there be a pair?
Tasha:因为一共买了5双
Tasha: Because we bought 5 pairs in total.
Tasha:没想到这么快就用完了
Tasha: Didn't expect to use them up so quickly.
Tasha:我一开始就应该买50双
Tasha: I should have bought 50 pairs from the start.
Tasha:你看其实别的有手套是不粘的对吧
Tasha: You see, other gloves don't stick, right?
Jake:挺好 有手套的那一边
Jake: It's good, the side with the gloves.
Tasha:想吃哪一个
Tasha: Which one do you want to eat?
Tasha:偷偷吃一点
Tasha: Sneak a little bite.
Jake:这个小配菜挺好看的
Jake: This little side dish looks nice.
Tasha:是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:我去太粘了
Jake: Oh, it's too sticky.
Tasha:先夹住这个然后然后粘这个
Tasha: First clip this, then stick this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:粘这个然后粘这个就可以吃到了
Tasha: Stick this and then stick this, and you can eat it.
Jake:还挺好
Jake: It's pretty good.
Jake:这是什么是什么东西怎么是这样的
Jake: What is this? Why does it look like this?
Tasha:炼奶 对
Tasha: Condensed milk, right.
Jake:炼奶
Jake: Condensed milk.
Tasha:奶盖
Tasha: Milk cap.
Tasha:意思就是
Tasha: It means...
Tasha:哦哟我哟哦哟我哟
Tasha: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha:您是不是又忘记了我教您的
Tasha: Did you forget what I taught you again?
Tasha:让它着陆于有粉的地方
Tasha: Let it land on the powdered spot.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:有粉的方不多了
Jake: There aren't many powdered spots left.
Tasha:这个盆好像有点大
Tasha: This bowl seems a bit big.
Tasha:这好小呀
Tasha: This is so small.
Tasha:哈哈你是为了弥补谁吗
Tasha: Haha, who are you trying to make up for?
Jake:4号
Jake: Number 4.
Jake:我想起了4号
Jake: I remember number 4.
Tasha:看得出来你弄得很不愉快
Tasha: I can tell you are not enjoying this.
Jake:很难愉快
Jake: It's hard to enjoy.
Jake:这个哎呦我靠好
Jake: This, oh, damn...
Jake:哈哈哈太nice you wait
Jake: Hahaha, that's nice, you wait.
Tasha:所以我一开始建议你要不把手套取了
Tasha: So at the beginning, I suggested you take off your gloves.
Tasha:直接揉这样的话
Tasha: And knead it directly like this.
Jake:好建议但是没有采纳
Jake: Good suggestion, but I didn't take it.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:并不知道
Jake: I didn't know.
Jake:它原来道理在这里
Jake: The logic was actually here.
Tasha:好好好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha:你把全部的搓完就行了这就结束了
Tasha: Once you finish kneading all of them, you're done.
Jake:好好难啊
Jake: It's so hard.
Tasha:不好玩了吗
Tasha: Not fun anymore?
Jake:好好好好玩
Jake: No, no, it's still fun.
Jake:哈哈哈那就难度有点高我草
Jake: Hahaha, it's just a bit too hard, damn.
Jake:我好像坐着搓
Jake: I think I need to sit down to knead.
Jake:我站着站不住
Jake: I can't stand.
Tasha:我一开始其实觉得挺好搓的
Tasha: At first, I thought it was quite easy to knead.
Tasha:你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Tasha:直到你把手套弄破
Tasha: Until you broke the gloves.
Jake:那真的就一个吗
Jake: Is it really just one?
Tasha:在此时换下是更不明智的选择
Tasha: Changing it now is an unwise choice.
Tasha:OK OK  这个这个 雨露均沾一下吧
Tasha: OK, OK, let's share it evenly.
Tasha:子落提
Tasha: Ziloti.
Tasha:电
Tasha: Electric.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha:q弹还拉丝
Tasha: It's so bouncy and stretchy.
Jake:不行不行
Jake: No, no.
Tasha:q弹还拉丝
Tasha: It's so bouncy and stretchy.
Jake:破了
Jake: It broke.
Tasha:这是麻薯你看你掌握了
Tasha: This is mochi, you got it.
Jake:哎我去
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha:全部的拉丝过程
Tasha: The whole stretching process.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Tasha:哈哈哈受不了了
Tasha: Hahaha, can't take it anymore.
Jake:哎呀 我操 这个粘粉了
Jake: Oh my god, it's sticky.
Tasha:没事没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:挤
Jake: Squeeze it.
Tasha:收 行行行
Tasha: Gather it, alright, alright.
Tasha:没有人看到它的制作过程
Tasha: If no one sees the process of making it.
Tasha:就不会觉得它恶心
Tasha: They wouldn't think it's gross.
Jake:其实随便一什么形状我都能揉成圆的对吗
Jake: Actually, I can make any shape into a round one, right?
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:那我就会
Jake: Then I can do it.
Jake:你想上去唱歌吗
Jake: Do you want to go up and sing?
Tasha:我不想唱没他那么好听
Tasha: I don't want to sing, not as good as him.
Tasha:那我就是个垃圾了
Tasha: Then I'm just trash.
Jake:那不不不不
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake:欧耶
Jake: Oh yeah.
Jake:这是我的手机
Jake: This is my phone.
Tasha:YES
Tasha: YES.
Tasha:哇 刚刚把它完成
Tasha: Wow, just finished it.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This is good.
Jake:这个我很满意
Jake: I'm very satisfied with this.
Tasha:杨老板改做巧克力味的了
Tasha: Jake switched to making chocolate flavored ones.
Tasha:你是不是觉得这边没关系
Tasha: You don't think it matters over here, right?
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this.
Jake:要不铺平点
Jake: How about we flatten it a bit?
Jake:也行吧
Jake: That works too.
Jake:因为我没有落地的地方
Jake: Because I have no place to land.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha:你看其实给你配一个助手
Tasha: You see, if you had an assistant,
Tasha:你就能做出很好的甜品了
Tasha: you could make really good desserts.
Jake:哇这么好
Jake: Wow, that good?
Tasha:要不要考虑考虑招募我哈哈哈
Tasha: How about considering hiring me? Haha.
Tasha:这这这你挤给谁吃的
Tasha: This, this, who are you squeezing this for?
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:太傻了
Jake: So silly.
Tasha:要尝尝巧克力味的吗
Tasha: Do you want to try the chocolate flavor?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:你吃了吗
Jake: Have you eaten?
Tasha:我我知道味道
Tasha: I know the taste.
Tasha:吃了好多次
Tasha: Ate it many times.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha:总体来说还挺好吃的
Tasha: Overall, it's pretty tasty.
Jake:确实也小
Jake: Indeed, it's small.
Tasha:你给自己挤个大的吧
Tasha: Make yourself a bigger one.
Tasha:哎呦我天呢
Tasha: Oh my goodness.
Katrina: 哎哟 你好愁啊
Katrina: Oh wow, you look so worried.
Tasha:有点像黑心作坊的感觉
Tasha: It kind of feels like a shady workshop.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Tasha:就是两个人
Tasha: Just two people.
Jake:嚯一般的店家不是这么做吗
Jake: Huh, isn't this how most shops do it?
Tasha:嗯会无菌上的吧
Tasha: Hmm, usually it's done in a sterile way.
Jake:好好好无菌怎么做
Jake: Alright, alright, how do we do it sterile?
Tasha:戴上正规手套
Tasha: Wear proper gloves.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha:而不是一个徒手一个戴破手套
Tasha: Not one person barehanded and the other with torn gloves.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 还给自己加的特效呢
Katrina: Even added special effects for yourself.
Jake:耶这个可以
Jake: Yeah, this works.
Jake:我们到时候那个盘子
Jake: When we get that plate...
Jake:里面放多少种类
Jake: How many types should we put in it?
Tasha:放什么多少种
Tasha: What types and how many?
Jake:甜品
Jake: Desserts.
Jake:外边的盘子大
Jake: The plate outside is big.
Shure: 可多特别特别油的
Shure: A lot, especially greasy ones.
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha:每个盘子放一种的话那得做很久吧
Tasha: If we put one type on each plate, it's gonna take forever.
Tasha:不过没关系
Tasha: But it's okay.
Jake:可以做很久
Jake: It can take a long time.
Tasha:可以做很久
Tasha: It can take a long time.
Jake:从昨天从明天开始做
Jake: Start doing it from yesterday, from tomorrow.
Jake:从明天开始做
Jake: Start from tomorrow.
Tasha:那你明天开始别休息了
Tasha: Then you won't get any rest starting tomorrow.
Jake:真的这么多
Jake: Is it really that much?
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha:什么这么多啊
Tasha: What do you mean that much?
Jake:哎呦好吃
Jake: Wow, it's delicious.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha:再来个巧克力味的啊哈
Tasha: Let's have another chocolate flavored one, ahaha.
Jake:哎呀 我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Tasha:不敢想这个怎么这个样子
Tasha: Can't imagine how this turned out like this.
Jake:真好真好
Jake: Really good, really good.
Tasha:耶这麻薯搓的很有杨老板的风格
Tasha: Yeah, this mochi has Jake's style all over it.
Tasha:就是每一个都独自形状
Tasha: Each one has its own shape.
Jake:不是我的
Jake: Not mine.
Jake:昨天那个奶油好歹我还是想给他一点
Jake: Yesterday, I still wanted to give him some of that cream.
Jake:形状
Jake: The shape.
Jake:就是昨天那个煮完了
Jake: Like, after it was cooked yesterday.
Jake:今天这个我
Jake: Today, I...
Tasha:被动的
Tasha: Passively.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:好剩下好多粉就倒上去吗
Jake: Okay, so just pour the rest of the powder in?
Tasha:不要了
Tasha: No, don't.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:耶 我觉得我要完工了
Jake: Yay, I think I'm about done.
Jake:来呗
Jake: Come on.
Tasha:把这个最丑的给你吃掉
Tasha: I'll let you eat the ugliest one.
Tasha:稍为好看一点的留给别人
Tasha: The slightly better looking ones are for others.
Jake:留着
Jake: Keep them.
Jake:我这个怎么办
Jake: What about this one?
Tasha:可以洗手了
Tasha: You can wash your hands now.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:这玩意怎么洗啊
Jake: How do you wash this thing?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Tasha:有点难洗吗
Tasha: Is it hard to wash?
Jake:有有点难洗
Jake: Yeah, it's kinda hard to wash.
Tasha:其实我的手也不好看
Tasha: Actually, my hands don't look good either.
Jake:那你先洗
Jake: Then you wash first.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:我到那边我用洗手液试试
Jake: I'll try using hand soap over there.
Tasha:呃洗洁
Tasha: Uh, dish soap.
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh.
Jake:我以为倒洗手液洗手液
Jake: I thought hand soap, hand soap.
Jake:洗手液稍微给手设计一些
Jake: Hand soap is a bit designed for hands.
Jake:你的手好洗吗
Jake: Are your hands clean?
Tasha:我洗完了
Tasha: I finished washing.
Jake:洗完了
Jake: Finished washing.
Jake:帮我看看我的手机我靠
Jake: Check my phone, damn.
Jake:我这手机是不是要洗
Jake: Does my phone need to be washed?
Tasha:完了完了完了完
Tasha: Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Jake::完球
Jake: It's over.
Jake:我完了
Jake: I'm doomed.
Tasha:稍微看下谁给你发短信了吗
Tasha: Take a quick look, did anyone text you?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh
Tasha:要干嘛吗
Tasha: Do you need something?
Jake:啊要要要
Jake: Ah, yes, yes, yes.
Jake:打个电话给谢彬竹
Jake: Call Xie Binzhu.
Tasha:洗好了吗
Tasha: Is it washed?
Tasha:洗完 洗
Tasha: Finished washing?
Jake:没没没 没洗
Jake: No, no, no, not washed.
Tasha:能洗吗
Tasha: Can it be washed?
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:我觉得有用
Jake: I think it's useful.
Tasha:怎么一个两个都不接电话呢
Tasha: Why is no one answering their phones?
Jake:一个两个都叫不起来
Jake: No one is waking up.
Jake:起床
Jake: Wake up.
Shure: 不难
Shure: Not difficult.
Tasha:说谁呢
Tasha: Who are you talking about?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:好了ok
Jake: Alright, okay.
Jake:哎不接算了
Jake: Well, if they don't answer, forget it.
Jake:不接一会再打一次
Jake: If they don't answer, I'll call again later.
Tasha:还有两个
Tasha: There are two more.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:是被遗落的
Tasha: They were left behind.
Jake:为什么被遗落呢
Jake: Why were they left behind?
Jake:唉等会
Jake: Wait a minute.
Tasha:喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha:问你接到了吗应该是呃
Tasha: Did you get it? It should be, uh...
Nicous: 导航导了半个小时快
Nicous: The navigation took almost half an hour.
Nicous: 耽误了点时间
Nicous: It took some time.
Tasha:哦行
Tasha: Oh, got it.
Jake:还用又又用这个
Jake: Still using this again?
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: Yeah, really.
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh my god.
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Ah.
Jake:你现在什么情况啊
Jake: What's your situation now?
Alice:她已经打完了吗
Lucia: Did she finish?
Nicous: 现在马上还有
Nicous: Almost, still more to go.
Nicous: 还有
Nicous: Still more.
Nicous: 还有三四分钟就见到她了
Nicous: In three or four minutes, I'll see her.
Jake:好 行行
Jake: Okay, good, good.
Jake:行  好
Jake:可以
Tasha:好完全不耽误事
Tasha:我们比他们还快嘞.
Jake:对
Tasha:都完成了
Jake:确实
Tasha:那你等我呢
Tasha:哎呦
Tasha:are you lady
Jake:ready怎么吃
Jake:你你不 吃啊
Tasha:我吃过一个了好吃吗
Jake:好吃
Tasha:行
Katrina: 假装自已弹弹
Tasha:你怎么蘸这么点
Tasha:你应该多蘸一点
Jake:我感觉我要插电
Jake:我看一眼我要不要插电了
Jake:我要插电了
Jake: I'm plugging it in.
Tasha:然后把这两个端上去就行
Tasha: Then just lift these two parts up.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:完成了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha:不要浪费了
Tasha: Don't waste it.
Jake:我们插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug it in.
Jake:没有电了
Jake: It's out of power.
Tasha:你去吧
Tasha: You go ahead.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:哦有电了我操
Jake: Oh, it's got power now, damn.
Tasha:对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:啊你等我一下
Jake: Ah, wait for me a sec.
Jake:帮忙
Jake: Help.
Tasha:噢 天呢
Tasha: Oh, gosh.
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:现在是一个
Jake: Now it's a...
Jake:不大用手的人
Jake: person who doesn't use hands much.
Jake:好粘还是好粘
Jake: Still sticky, so sticky.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alrighty.
Jake:这干嘛呀
Jake: What's this for?
Tasha:草莓熟透了你看
Tasha: The strawberries are ripe, look.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:看到了要把它干掉
Jake: When you see it, you need to finish it off.
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:芒果这边要把它干掉
Jake: The mango here, it needs to be finished off.
Jake:Mango我要吃Mango
Jake: Mango, I want to eat Mango.
Tasha:Mango is in bread
Tasha: Mango is in the bread.
Jake:吃bread
Jake: Eat bread.
Jake:哦 你还活着
Jake: Oh, you're still alive.
Jake:放着吧 今晚收拾吧
Jake: Just leave it, we'll clean it up tonight.
Jake:这玩意怎么收呢
Jake: How do we clean this?
Tasha:怎么收
Tasha: How to clean it?
Jake:怎么把它给解决掉
Jake: How do we get rid of it?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:直接吃掉
Tasha: Just eat it.
Jake:好给你
Jake: Okay, here you go.
Jake:给你一个
Jake: Here's one for you.
Jake:你不吃了吗
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Tasha:一人一个呀
Tasha: One each.
Jake:也行
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:好了我们偷偷把草莓给干掉
Tasha: Alright, let's secretly finish off the strawberries.
Jake:下一步就是
Jake: The next step is...
Jake:是不是多少过分了点
Jake: Isn't this a bit too much?
Jake:要不等他们回来
Jake: Should we wait for them to come back?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:嗯等他们分点
Jake: Yeah, and share a bit with them.
Jake:我先给弄上去
Jake: I'll take care of this first.
Jake:好不
Jake: Okay?
Tasha:行可以啊
Tasha: Sure, that's fine.
Tasha:走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha:你有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Do you need to take anything?
Tasha:你手机呢
Tasha: Where's your phone?
Tasha:你看
Tasha: Look.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Jake:咋的唱累了
Jake: What's wrong, tired of singing?
Shure: 我现在在思考
Shure: I'm thinking now.
Shure: 定下歌曲
Shure: Finalizing the song.
Jake:自己作词
Jake: Writing your own lyrics?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Katrina: 你就唱草履虫拉倒吧
Katrina: Just sing about paramecium and be done with it.
Jake:你把词写了让人唱
Jake: You write the lyrics and let someone else sing them.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:这是我刚刚
Jake: This is what I just...
Jake:学习的
Jake: Learned.
Tasha:老师做的
Tasha: Made by the teacher.
Tasha:杨老师做的
Tasha: Made by Teacher Jake.
Jake:学习的
Jake: Learned.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha:你有没有发现你没有带筷子上来
Tasha: Did you realize you didn't bring chopsticks?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha:大家怎么吃啊
Tasha: How is everyone going to eat?
Katrina: 这已经做好了
Katrina: It's already done.
Lucia:啊啥
Lucia: Ah, what?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 好厉害啊
Katrina: So impressive.
Katrina: 这东西做的很快吗居然
Katrina: Did you make this quickly?
Jake:这东西做的我馋死了
Jake: This stuff is so appetizing.
Jake:我靠满手的这个
Jake: My hands are covered in this.
Shure: 面
Shure: Dough.
Jake:黏的
Jake: Sticky.
Jake:可粘了洗了10分钟的手
Jake: It's so sticky, I washed my hands for 10 minutes.
Jake:他要是 哎露西呢
Jake: By the way, where is Lucia?
Tasha:我们就坐在这是吗
Tasha: Are we just sitting here?
Jake:我们就坐在这
Jake: We're just sitting here.
Tasha:你要不要把大垫子拖出来
Tasha: Do you want to pull out the big mat?
Jake:大垫子
Jake: The big mat?
Shure: 就把那个
Shure: Just that one.
Jake:哦你的那个大垫子也用不着吧
Jake: Oh, you probably don't need the big mat.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:就这个足够了
Jake: This is enough.
Katrina: 那就一起讨论呗
Katrina: Then let's discuss together.
Jake:来桃子桃子
Jake: Come on, peaches, peaches.
Shure: 露西亚你会唱是吧
Shure: Lucia, you can sing, right?
Katrina: 他不是露西亚
Katrina: He's not Lucia.
Katrina: 他是微微
Katrina: He's Weiwei.
Jake:你完了
Jake: You're done for.
Shure: 你叫什么露西亚
Shure: Why did you call him Lucia?
Katrina: 我是子轩
Katrina: I'm Zixuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我是子轩
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm Zixuan.
Jake:子轩好 你好子轩
Jake: Hello Zixuan, hi Zixuan.
Tasha:你完了
Tasha: You're done for.
Jake:你好子轩
Jake: Hi Zixuan.
Jake:不 不 不
Jake: No, no, no.
Katrina: 他是露西亚我是
Katrina: He's Lucia, I'm...
Tasha:我叫什么
Tasha: What's my name?
Jake:我是露西亚
Jake: I'm Lucia.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 你你叫塔莎
Shure: You're Tasha.
Jake:我叫什么
Jake: What's my name?
Jake:我叫露西亚
Jake: I'm Lucia.
Shure: 你叫Jing Kang
Shure: Your name is Jing Kang.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:我靠什么东西
Jake: What the heck is that?
Tasha:他就只能叫他有他
Tasha: He can only be called...
Tasha:他有英文名吗
Tasha: Does he have an English name?
Shure: Jing Kang
Shure: Jing Kang.
Tasha:你有英文名吗
Tasha: Do you have an English name?
Jake:我可以有
Jake: I can have one.
Jake:给给一个
Jake: Give me one.
Shure: JK young
Shure: JK Young.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:我靠
Jake: What the heck.
Shure: number seven JKyoung
Shure: Number seven, JK Young.
Jake:为什么seven
Jake: Why seven?
Jake:为什么是seven啊
Jake: Why is it seven?
Shure: 没有就是脑袋里面第一个蹦的
Shure: No reason, just the first thing that came to mind.
Shure: 就是number seven
Shure: Just number seven.
Shure: 韦世豪哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Wei Shihao, hahaha.
Shure: 什么你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: What, you don't know this joke?
Jake:再说一遍
Jake: Say it again.
Shure: number seven韦世豪
Shure: Number seven, Wei Shihao.
Jake:韦世豪我知道了啊
Jake: Wei Shihao, got it.
Shure: 然后哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then, hahaha.
Jake:我上回看到踢球了
Jake: I saw him playing soccer last time.
Jake:在那个中国队踢平新加坡
Jake: In that match where China drew with Singapore.
Jake:逼平新加坡啊
Jake: They forced a draw with Singapore.
Jake:对中国国足
Jake: Right, the Chinese national team.
Jake:逼平新家坡
Jake: Forced a draw with Singapore.
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Katrina: 想一首大家都会的欢快的歌
Katrina: Think of a cheerful song that everyone knows.
Shure: 你们也可以唱你家乡的歌
Shure: You can also sing a song from your hometown.
Tasha:那必须要唱那种EMO神曲
Tasha: Then it has to be an EMO anthem.
Katrina: EMO选了一个
Katrina: EMO picked one.
Katrina: 那个安静一点
Katrina: The quieter one.
Katrina: 要么唯一
Katrina: Or "The Only One".
Katrina: 要么就那个perfect
Katrina: Or maybe "Perfect".
Katrina: 就黄老板那个
Katrina: The one by Ed Sheeran.
Katrina: 应该这个
Katrina: Probably this one.
Katrina: 这两个大家都比较熟吧
Katrina: These two are quite familiar to everyone, right?
Shure: 那唱那什么吧
Shure: Then let's sing that.
Shure: 唱卡丘莎
Shure: Sing "Katyusha".
Shure: 你家乡的小曲
Shure: A little tune from your hometown.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 想想动动你聪明的小脑瓜
Shure: Use your clever little brain.
Katrina: 看看你刚刚那个new boy
Katrina: Look at your "new boy".
Katrina: new boy
Katrina: New boy.
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听了
Katrina: The two of us sang horribly.
Shure: 把把我去了
Shure: I nailed it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听
Katrina: We sang terribly.
Shure: 不管把我去开
Shure: No matter what, I nailed it.
Tasha:他不难听
Tasha: He didn't sing badly.
Tasha:是这个意思吗
Tasha: Is that what you mean?
Shure: 你会唱new boy
Shure: Do you know how to sing "new boy"?
Shure: 听过吗
Shure: Heard it before?
Shure: 是呀哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, hahaha.
Katrina: 这可这人多一点
Katrina: This, but with more people.
Shure: 你觉得唱歌如何
Shure: How do you feel about singing?
Tasha:非常不好听
Tasha: Very unpleasant.
Shure: 那我们唱哪首歌
Shure: So which song should we sing?
Shure: 我们唱那首西城男孩 吧
Shure: Let's sing a Westlife song.
Katrina: 好就是
Katrina: Okay, that's it.
Katrina: 好这个我会打
Katrina: Okay, I can play that.
Shure: 好这个我不会弹
Shure: Okay, I can't play that.
Katrina: 这个太难了他明白
Katrina: It's too hard, he understands.
Katrina: 这不嗨呀我以为这个摇滚的会嗨一点
Katrina: This isn't hype, I thought rock would be more exciting.
Katrina: 到了专业的余额是吧
Katrina: Now it's down to the professionals.
Katrina: 这样给你拍一张
Katrina: Let's take a picture like this.
Shure: 这根本就不可以
Shure: This is absolutely not possible.
Shure: 用一把木的吉他给他
Shure: Give him a wooden guitar.
Shure: 就是那种欢快跳搓
Shure: The kind that makes you want to dance joyfully.
Shure: 水手
Shure: Sailor.
Shure: 这个很跳搓
Shure: This is really lively.
Shure: 水手公园那个旮旯乐队
Shure: The band from that corner of Sailor Park.
Jake:不唱英文真听不出来
Jake: If it's not in English, you can't tell.
Shure: 哈哈确实哈哈
Shure: Haha, indeed, haha.
Katrina: 这能用吉他弹出来吗
Katrina: Can this be played with a guitar?
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Should be able to.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Shure: 不行就是新造的人好吧
Shure: No, it's just a new person, okay.
Jake:可以迎接他们一下
Jake: We can welcome them.
Jake:把他们拐到一个小边上
Jake: Lead them to a small corner.
Katrina: 海域恋你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard "Sea Love"?
Katrina: 海域恋也行
Katrina: "Sea Love" is also good.
Katrina: 那就这个开场
Katrina: Let's start with this.
Katrina: 这个就大家一起唱
Katrina: Everyone can sing along.
Katrina: 这听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard this?
Katrina: 孙燕姿的第一天
Katrina: "First Day" by Stefanie Sun.
Shure: 第一天
Shure: "First Day".
Shure: 想起来第一次告白
Shure: Reminds me of the first confession.
Jake:忙着唱别的歌去了
Jake: Busy singing other songs.
Shure: 心燥的人
Shure: An anxious person.
Katrina: 还下雨嘞这个人听过吗
Katrina: It's raining, have you heard this person?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 塔莎给的议建
Shure: Suggestion given by Tasha.
Shure: 这听过了
Shure: I've heard this one.
Katrina: 感觉这歌挺好唱
Katrina: Feels like this song is easy to sing.
Katrina: 试一下不
Katrina: Want to give it a try?
Jake:这得一群人一起唱然后在啊啊啊
Jake: It needs a group to sing together, and then like, ah ah ah.
Jake:你这是蓝莓味的吗
Jake: Is this blueberry flavored?
Katrina: 哪首歌啊
Katrina: Which song is it?
Shure: 周楚除三害
Shure: "Zhou Chu Eliminates the Three Harms".
Shure: 知道这个电影吗
Shure: Do you know this movie?
Katrina: 哦知道知道
Katrina: Oh, I know, I know.
Katrina: 但我没看
Katrina: But I haven't seen it.
Shure: 就是中间那个
Shure: It's the one in the middle.
Shure: 就是前段时间特别火的那个
Shure: The one that was really popular recently.
Shure: 棒棒棒挨个打死
Shure: Bam bam bam, killing them one by one.
Shure: 好吧 那得想想
Shure: Alright, let me think about it.
Katrina: 一般那开场还远着
Katrina: Usually, the opening is still far away.
Katrina: 我们居然用我的开
Katrina: I can't believe we started with my...
Katrina: 我的未来式开过
Katrina: ...future tense opening.
Katrina: 哈哈好像那个
Katrina: Haha, it seems like...
Shure: 我们我知道了
Shure: I got it.
Shure: 开心超人听过吗
Shure: Have you heard of Happy Superman?
Katrina: 我有时候会
Katrina: Sometimes, yeah.
Katrina: 应该 听过
Katrina: I think I've heard of it.
Tasha:哦我知道那个
Tasha: Oh, I know that one.
Shure: 听过吗这首歌
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Jake:听过
Jake: Yeah, I've heard it.
Katrina: 好找这种耳熟能祥家喻户晓的
Katrina: It's easy to find, it's so well-known.
Katrina: 哎怎么了
Katrina: Hey, what's up?
Nicous: 你问一下杨老板
Nicous: Ask Jake.
Nicous: 密码多少
Nicous: What's the password?
Katrina: 门口吗 3
Katrina: For the door? 3...
Jake:对
Jake: Yep.
Jake:人类都记住了
Jake: Everyone, remember this.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哎呀回来啦
Jake: Hey, you’re back!
Alice:你进来了吗
Alice: Did you come in?
Alice:要上楼吗
Alice: Do you want to go upstairs?
Jake:上吧
Jake: Sure, let’s go.
Alice:上吧
Alice: Let’s go.
Jake:外面下雨了吗
Jake: Is it raining outside?
Nicous: 还没下呢
Nicous: Not yet.
露丝:没下呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:来坐
Jake: Come, have a seat.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:哎呀 不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry.
Lucia:哎呀
Lucia: Oh dear.
Jake:这边也可以坐
Jake: You can sit here too.
Jake:大伙现在在讨论
Jake: Everyone is discussing now.
Jake:哎最后一天唱点啥
Jake: Hey, what should we sing on the last day?
Jake:这咱就不跳舞了
Jake: We’re not dancing.
Katrina: 你们的朋友会唱歌吗
Katrina: Do your friends sing?
Lucia:卡拉OK的唱法吗
Lucia: Karaoke style singing?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:就就就这种唱法
Jake: Yeah, just this kind of singing.
Lucia:不会弹吉他
Lucia: I can't play the guitar.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Katrina: 到时候反正他有音响
Katrina: Anyway, he'll have a sound system.
Katrina: 直接那个呗
Katrina: Just go directly with that.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina: 就搞个话筒
Katrina: Just get a microphone.
Jake:还有话桶
Jake: And a mic stand.
Katrina: 然后唱歌也可以获得获得
Katrina: Then we can sing and still get it done.
Jake:恩
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Alice:我会骑牛
Alice: I can ride a bull.
Alice:正威的唱法
Alice: The proper singing technique.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure!
Shure: 蛋黄的长裙
Shure: Egg yolk-colored long dress.
Shure: 蓬松的头发
Shure: Fluffy hair.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia:我们不是合唱吗
Lucia: Aren't we doing a duet?
Katrina: 是合唱所以在挑两首歌
Katrina: Yes, a duet, so we're picking two songs.
Katrina: 一首就开场欢快一点
Katrina: One for a lively opening.
Katrina: 一首就是适合晚上的慢悠悠的那种
Katrina: And one that's more relaxed, suitable for the evening.
Katrina: 开场的话有听这个
Katrina: For the opening, have you heard this one?
Katrina: 开心超人你听过吗
Katrina: Happy Superhero, have you heard of it?
Lucia::哪个
Lucia: Which one?
Shure: 结尾想好了
Shure: I've figured out the ending.
Jake:哈哈哈可拉倒吧
Jake: Hahaha, as if.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 可以整的
Shure: It can be done.
Lucia:来插点电插点电
Lucia: Let's plug in some power.
Katrina: 我也要插
Katrina: I need to plug in too.
Shure: 给我来一个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank.
Lucia:我需要一个充电宝宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 给我来个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
修厦:上春山是吧
Shure: Heading to the Spring Mountain, right?
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: Then...
Lucia:不要再大合唱了
Lucia: No more group singing.
Katrina: 也行也行
Katrina: That's fine, that's fine.
Katrina: 每人唱一句工作量就小一点
Katrina: If everyone sings one line, the workload will be smaller.
Lucia:17
Lucia: 17
Jake:17没事多很多对
Jake: 17, it's okay, a lot more, right.
Lucia:我信你
Lucia: I trust you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:那给你一个
Jake: Then I'll give you one.
Lucia:没事没事不开玩笑
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, just kidding.
Jake:那我给你三个四个
Jake: Then I'll give you three or four.
Lucia:行行行用完了我随时换
Lucia: Sure, sure, I'll switch whenever I'm done.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure: 这是她做的吗
Shure: Did she make this?
Katrina: 对但你可以拿双筷子吗
Katrina: Yes, but can you grab a pair of chopsticks?
Tasha:筷子呢
Tasha: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 哦我需要个宝
Shure: Oh, I need a treasure.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:你给你一个宝
Jake: Here, a treasure for you.
Jake:来 宝
Jake: Here, treasure.
Jake:每人拧一个
Jake: Everyone twist one.
Lucia:我洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands.
Lucia:我刚从那个啥医院回来
Lucia: I just came back from the hospital.
Lucia:不敢直接接触吃的
Lucia: I don't dare to touch the food directly.
Katrina: 尝尝
Katrina: Try it.
Katrina: 你这是开心超人的歌吗
Katrina: Is this the song of Happy Superman?
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Ah, yes.
Katrina: 怎么缠着悲悲伤的感觉
Katrina: Why does it feel so sad?
Shure: 我可以把
Shure: Can I...
Katrina: 哎哎要怎么吃
Katrina: Hey, hey, how do you eat this?
Tasha:还先蘸这个再蘸这个
Tasha: First dip in this, then dip in that.
Nicous: 这么讲究
Nicous: So fancy.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 可是我刚刚舔过来的
Shure: But I just licked it.
Katrina: 哈哈你算了
Katrina: Haha, never mind then.
Tasha:蘸蘸汤
Tasha: Dip it in the soup.
Jake:来
Jake: Here.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Jake:嗯来了来了来
Jake: Hmm, here it comes, here it comes.
Lucia:谢谢嗯嗯
Lucia: Thanks, mmm.
Lucia:年糕吗
Lucia: Rice cake?
Tasha:麻薯
Tasha: Mochi.
Jake:看看这个店
Jake: Look at this store.
Lucia:这两个是什么味
Lucia: What flavors are these two?
Tasha:豆乳的和可可的
Tasha: Soy milk and cocoa.
Lucia:啊谢谢吃一个
Lucia: Ah, thanks. I'll have one.
Katrina: 他0.5倍速
Katrina: He's at 0.5x speed.
Lucia:可以蘸着吗
Lucia: Can I dip it?
Tasha:要多蘸
Tasha: Dip a lot.
Lucia:碗都要给我蘸走了
Lucia: I'm gonna dip the whole bowl.
Katrina: 快点
Katrina: Hurry up.
Tasha:快给我二成分成吧我亲力教教学
Tasha: Quickly, give me 20% of the shares. I'll personally teach.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia:有你去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: If you go to places with a lot of Chinese students, they definitely have it.
Tasha:他说有没有竞争力
Tasha: He asked if it's competitive.
Lucia:有竞争力啊
Lucia: It is competitive.
Lucia:就是去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: I mean, in places with a lot of Chinese students, they definitely have it.
Tasha:那不是有市场吗
Tasha: Doesn't that mean there's a market?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha:不是我的意思是啊
Tasha: No, what I mean is...
Jake:这也没多少
Jake: This isn't much.
Tasha:利润很大
Tasha: The profit is huge.
Jake:没关系不要看了
Jake: It's okay, don't worry about it.
Lucia:我先放一下
Lucia: I'll just put it down for now.
Tasha:去办一个
Tasha: Go and get one.
Lucia:拿瓶水
Lucia: Grab a bottle of water.
Tasha:开家店
Tasha: Open a store.
Lucia:这水应该可以喝吧
Lucia: This water should be drinkable, right?
Lucia:我刚看了
Lucia: I just checked.
Jake:喝喝
Jake: Drink it.
Lucia:医生让我多喝点水哦
Lucia: The doctor told me to drink more water.
Lucia:我想申请一下这疫苗能报销吗
Lucia: I want to apply for reimbursement for this vaccine.
Jake:呃能报能报
Jake: Uh, it can be reimbursed.
Jake:报了
Jake: It's reimbursed.
Lucia:好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks a lot.
Lucia:能算工伤吗
Lucia: Can it be considered a work injury?
Lucia:我甚至期待项目结束还得再打两针
Lucia: I'm even expecting to get two more shots after the project ends.
Jake:啊行行
Jake: Oh, sure.
Tasha:没有去新疆学啊
Tasha: Didn't go to Xinjiang to study?
Nicous: 这个不是这个不是在哪里学
Nicous: This isn't, this isn't about where you study.
Tasha:这个没有在哪学
Tasha: There's no specific place to study this.
Shure: 这不是假的吗
Shure: Isn't this fake?
Shure: 哎呦你这不听
Shure: Hey, you're not listening.
Lucia:万一我今天晚上发烧了的话
Lucia: What if I get a fever tonight?
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好待会可以
Jake: Alright, we can do that later.
Lucia:请大家那个
Lucia: Everyone, please...
Tasha:会发烧的
Tasha: You might get a fever.
Lucia:帮我冻点冰水哈哈哈
Lucia: Get me some ice water, hahaha.
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia:没有没有应该不会就
Lucia: No, no, it should be fine.
Tasha:那不是假的吗
Tasha: Isn't that fake?
Jake:看看你你伤
Jake: Look at you, you're hurt.
Lucia:这个就是他
Lucia: This is him.
Lucia:这就到现在还在红中
Lucia: It's still red even now.
Lucia:看这和这个地方
Lucia: Look at this and that spot.
Lucia:对现在好像又比我下午好一点了
Lucia: Yeah, it seems a bit better than this afternoon.
Jake:OKOK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia:就我特还有点
Lucia:就我确实还有点红然后
Lucia: It's still a bit red and...
Katrina: 我当时还特崇拜你来
Katrina: I really admired you back then.
Jake:应该还行问题不大
Jake: It should be fine, no big deal.
Lucia:对理论上应该问题不大但是
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically it should be fine, but...
Jake:多打几针几挺好
Jake: Just get a few more shots, it'll be fine.
Lucia:规定是必须要至少要打4次或者5针
Lucia: The rule is you need at least 4 or 5 shots.
Lucia:然后最少最少要打4针
Lucia: At least 4 shots.
Lucia:就是打5针
Lucia: That's 5 shots.
Lucia:就是28天
Lucia: So, 28 days.
Lucia:然后隔多久
Lucia: Then, how long in between?
Lucia: 隔一星期打一针
Lucia: One shot every week.
Lucia:如果是打4针就是今天要打两针
Lucia: If it's 4 shots, you need two today.
Lucia:对所以我两边都打了一针
Lucia: Yeah, so I got one on each side.
Jake:我以前也被猫抓了
Jake: I was scratched by a cat before.
Jake:然后我我我是我是在美国住一个LMB
Jake: And I was living in an Airbnb in the US.
Jake:然后被那边有一只猫抓了
Jake: And got scratched by a cat there.
Jake:然后抓了就
Jake: And then...
Shure: 没有可乐了
Shure: No more cola.
Jake:我和房东房东说打过哦
Jake: I told the landlord and he said to get a shot.
Jake:然后我我我我也就是
Jake: And then I...
Jake:虽然第一天很慌但是后来也不管了
Jake: Was really nervous the first day but then I didn't care anymore.
Lucia:对我今天还专门去咖啡馆问了
Lucia: Yeah, I even went to the café today to ask.
Lucia:我说这这小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if the puppy had vaccination records.
Lucia:然后他们说就是就是
Lucia: And they said, well...
Lucia:这个狗现在的疫苗他们还没带去打
Lucia: The puppy hasn't been vaccinated yet.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍说打过
Lucia: But the kennel said it had been vaccinated.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:但是就是狗舍没有给他们给疫苗本
Lucia: But the kennel didn't give them the vaccination records.
Lucia:然后我觉得啊那要不然回去打一下吧
Lucia: So I thought, maybe we should go get it vaccinated.
Jake:还是不够踏实对
Jake: Still not reassuring, right?
Lucia:对不对
Lucia: Right?
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia:所以我就
Lucia: So I...
Lucia:然后我问了一下我我那个我家人
Lucia: Then I asked my family.
Lucia:我妈说他朋友养猫
Lucia: My mom said her friend has a cat.
Lucia:然后被自己家猫抓了
Lucia: And got scratched by their cat.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia:就也去打了
Lucia: And they went to get vaccinated too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:然后我本来想着对
Lucia: So I thought, yeah...
Jake:对打一个
Jake: Yeah, get a shot.
Lucia:就是我可能很快就打回来了啊
Lucia: I might get it done quickly.
Jake:对我之被抓的时候
Jake: Yeah, when I got scratched...
Jake:那种大长狗
Jake: By a big dog.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:我们打算开始之前打算回来了
Lucia: We planned to do it before we start.
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because it's quite close.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Katrina: 百分百致死率
Katrina: 100% fatality rate.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:对但是那个因为他那是值班嘛
Lucia: But since they're on duty...
Lucia:然后所以我就要等一下
Lucia: So I had to wait a bit.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia:那个医生
Lucia: The doctor.
Lucia:然后我还要再咨询一下他是怎么回事
Lucia: I need to consult with them about what to do.
Katrina: 那概率还很低
Katrina: The probability is very low.
Shure: 大家有看到我的手机吗
Shure: Has anyone seen my phone?
Lucia:然后怎么打
Lucia: And how to get vaccinated.
Lucia:然后所以就稍微晚了一点
Lucia: So it took a bit longer.
Jake:打个电话
Jake: Make a call.
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri
Jake:那个电话
Jake: That phone
Katrina: 疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is the vaccine per shot?
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri
Katrina: 你那疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is your vaccine per shot?
Shure: 在我的iPhone上播放声音算是
Shure: Play sound on my iPhone
Lucia:基本上算是100块钱一针
Lucia: It's basically around 100 per shot
Katrina: 哦那还很便宜
Katrina: Oh, that's quite cheap
Lucia:对但是要打五针或者四针
Lucia: Yes, but you need to get five or four shots
Lucia:就是打四针的话
Lucia: If you get four shots
Lucia:你就是第一天打的时候要打两针
Lucia: You'll need two shots on the first day
Lucia:左右胳膊上各一针
Lucia: One on each arm
Alice:这个疫苗价钱还不一样的吗
Alice: Are the vaccine prices different?
Lucia:对还有300的哦
Lucia: Yes, there are also ones for 300
Lucia:但我觉得310只有点太夸张了
Lucia: But I think 310 is a bit too much
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia:而且就是
Lucia: And also
Katrina: 他们的功能不都是抑制吗
Katrina: Don't they all just suppress it?
Katrina: 难道还有什么抑制得快一点
Katrina: Is there one that suppresses it faster?
Lucia:好像没啥区别
Lucia: Doesn't seem like there's a difference
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah
Lucia:应该是没啥区别
Lucia: There shouldn't be any difference
Alice:他是根据什么来给你选针的呀
Alice: How do they choose which shot to give you?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know
Alice:这100多跟300多有什么区别啊
Alice: What's the difference between the 100 and 300 ones?
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: No idea
Lucia:咱也不知道啊
Lucia: We don't know either
Alice:我们之前打了
Alice: We got it before
Alice:就打完一一个就快2,000
Alice: And one shot cost almost 2,000
Katrina: 定歌定歌定歌定歌定歌
Katrina: Pick a song, pick a song, pick a song
Lucia:哦那你可能那
Lucia: Oh, maybe
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because that place is quite close
Lucia:那你那那就是你说的这种可能是300一针的
Lucia: So maybe the one you mentioned is 300 per shot
Shure: 定歌快快定完歌
Shure: Pick a song quickly
Katrina: 定完歌睡觉了
Katrina: Pick a song and then sleep
Lucia:如果300多就打完了就是1500对吧
Lucia: If it's 300 each, then it's 1500 in total, right?
Shure: 我睡觉觉
Shure: I'm going to sleep
Alice:那个好像三针
Alice: That one seems to be three shots
Lucia:三针
Lucia: Three shots
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either
Alice:反正我妈去打的
Alice: Anyway, my mom went to get it.
Lucia:我妈他朋友打的就
Lucia: My mom's friend also got it.
Lucia:也是100块钱一针的
Lucia: It was 100 bucks per shot.
Lucia:然后我觉得这应该就可以了
Lucia: So I think it should be fine.
Jake:OKOKOKOK
Jake: OKOKOKOK
Katrina: 要不听一下这歌
Katrina: How about we listen to this song?
Katrina: 这应该合唱出来会好听
Katrina: It would sound nice as a duet.
Lucia:希望我今天晚上不要发烧
Lucia: I hope I don't get a fever tonight.
Lucia:医生说常见的副作用是可能会发烧
Lucia: The doctor said a common side effect is fever.
Jake:哦就是打疫苗发烧
Jake: Oh, so you might get a fever from the vaccine.
Lucia:对打疫苗发烧对
Lucia: Yeah, a fever from the vaccine, right.
Shure: 来先听一下下歌
Shure: Let's listen to the song first.
Shure: 听一下歌
Shure: Listen to the song.
Shure: 这首歌大家听过吗
Shure: Have you all heard this song before?